what is the perimeter of the shape each
square in the grid is a 1 by 1
centimeter square
so all we have to do is add up the
lengths of these blue segments right
over here and they they put it on this
nice grid and each box here is one by
one so we could let's say we start up
here we want to make sure that we only
go to where we started and we don't
double count so we this perimeter is 1 2
3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11
12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24
centimeters long so it is 24 centimeters
the other way we could have thought
about this is you could have looked at
the length of each of these sides so
this is one plus two plus three plus one
plus three plus one plus what is this
five plus two
plus four plus two and you would have
also gotten 24 centimeters let's do a
couple more of these what is the
perimeter of the square so once again
it's the length of all of the segments
that define the outside boundary of the
square and by definition a square all of
its sides are equal so you have four
sides that are all seven meters long so
you could say it's 7 meters plus 7
meters plus 7 meters plus 7 meters or
it's 4 times 7 meters or 28 meters
28 meters let's do one more
what is the perimeter of the regular
pentagon
so it's a regular pentagon which means
all of its sides have the same length
and they give us a side of one the
length of one is two so all of the sides
have length two so it's going to be two
plus two plus two plus two plus two or
essentially five twos or another way of
thinking about is it's five times two
which is going to be which is going to
be
ten you have five sides of this pentagon
each of those sides are two
units long so two units long times five
sides is going to be 10 units